[Music]
and welcome back everybody to amazing
episode of the careful boys where we
have the buff table over here featuring
myself and Jared and Mike Dr Mike as we
like to call them here we
go we got husbands of Latino Heat and
then we got the white
sister white by proxy white by proxy
There It Is We're representing hey so
something for all of us you know I've
never done that wave before till nowb
some we wanted to talk about are some
fad diets we wanted to go into because
you guys are the authorities you guys
are the intelligence Factor on how to
lay it down so that people who are into
fat diets can know what are the best
ones and what which ones cuz everybody
swears by like oh it's it's Atkin season
oh it's vegetarian season it's vegan
season it's carnivore season but which
one Carnivor is a season well I'm just
saying like there's always a fat right
there's a diet called carnivore diet
yeah they're like I swear
keto I swear by this and it's it's like
well you're all fit and you're all
successful in it but I don't know which
one to choose also there's probably not
a one siiz fits all right something for
somebody might not work for somebody
else we're all one size over here that's
right jacked you keep thinking that you
keep thinking you're more jacked than we
are we're dragging you back I like this
table in taller better looking well
you're definitely taller and better
looking go all day stop
it
so let's talk about what's a fat diet
right now actually if it has a name what
if it has a name diet yeah but you know
it's like somebody else calls it that we
don't call it the Renaissance diet right
you should just do this and it's our
diet but it's not a fat diet
about we don't really have a diet ours
is just like here's the principles
determined by science of what works
what's a what's a fad diet that you guys
completely cringe at and and then we'll
Market your guys' Renaissance diet
brought to you by RP yes because we're
in the sports science realm and we deal
with like bodybuilders highle
powerlifters anybody in sport anything
that completely gets rid of a food group
is ridiculous especially carbohydrates
because carbohydrates like they make one
food group evil like no meat no grain
whatever yeah so especially keto for
like performance is just complete
garbage but you get tired carnivore is
an extreme version of Keto where you
only eat depending on the type of
carnivore you do
it's only meat like it's a very
masculine diet it makes you feel all
like lion and wolf and [__] like that
but I it's not highly effective for your
goals the thing about dieting is when
you look at it from like a principal
perspective you can check some decent
High effect Boxes by following just a
couple simple Concepts like whatever it
is your body wants to eat if you just
eat a little bit less every day and move
a little more you're actually going to
get like quite a bit leaner and
healthier and so there's so many correct
ways to to do decent diets that many
people find a decent diet that works for
them and they're like they become kind
of cult members about it they're like
this is the [__] [__] it's the
[__] best and you're like okay it's
definitely has its ups and downs you're
like you [__]
[__] I'll yeah what are some
principles for like a common person to
follow if they just want to go what to
just to quick or three quick things I
can do totally so I got two two right
off the right off the top one is try not
to stuff yourself like a [__] pig all
the goddamn time that's one of the
hardest scientists have narrow down
that's what makes you
fat not you you're
amazing hard time concentrating but um
yeah no it's like you know there's if
you're trying to eat like a gazillion of
[__] donuts and you're like how do I
fit this into a diet I can rationalize
to myself like better just rationalize
being fat cuz that's what's coming and
so one of them is like you if you can
eat a little less portion control it's
always a plus if you want to get leaner
and the other one is stick to mostly
healthy foods and I get a lot of flat
personally for this one actually as kind
of a science Communicator because people
sometimes like to get really pedantic
and say well there's no such thing as
healthy it's all contextual like you
know there are contexts on in which
getting stabbed in the throat probably
is pretty good but they're very small
number am I making your uncomfortable
knives guy with two knives and
[__]
Bo must stabbing what throat but like so
people will say what do you mean by
healthy food and I mean some combination
of lean meats lean protein sources if
you're vegan dope uh fruits veggies
whole grains and healthy fats like fats
that are more like polyunsaturated
monosaturated like uh olive oil canola
oil nut Butters nuts you know what I'm
saying [__] you see at the store like no
offense like white women
buy and yeah yeah give me a few see if I
see if it's in my fridge yeah like some
quinoa or some [__] like that so there
you go you're not that white um oat milk
almond milk close
enough got you [__] cashew milk be
like yeah good enough but I still
consume milk products like cottage
cheese and great
yogurt she's got like casserole and
stuff too yeah yeah I put like raisins
in that [__] fruit salads you know tuna
salads person of all time yeah no I'm
just trying to name as many white Foods
as I can
think um but yeah people is healthy [__]
right lean proteins veggies fruits whole
grains and healthy fats you [__] know
it when you see it like there's very few
people you come up to any socioeconomic
uh situation any educational background
you give him a [__] cheeseburger and
like a [__] cheese dripping out the
[__] in a bag of [__] chips and
you're like is this healthy
so few people are going to be like well
I'm not sure the literature on that is
unclear think so and you're going to be
you know what you're right and you hand
the [__] you hand somebody like
a cut up apple and a [__] little
handful of [__] pistachios and like a
lean salmon cut you like is this bad for
you very few people are going to be like
her fish has mercury you know it's
unlikely so just try to stick to more
healthy options and try not to stuff
yourself to the brim all the [__]
time and if you can do that that that's
like 60 or 70% of dieting right there so
any diet you can do that through if it's
carnivore for you if it's vegan cuz
vegan can Che all the boxes carnivore
doesn't quite check them all but it can
be a great way to control calories just
be honest if somebody tells you like
only [__] you can eat is beef straight
up for the next 90 days beef only how
much are you going to overeat can you
imagine someone's like how's your
weekend you're like H it's just [__]
Netflix Marathon got a hold of me and I
I ate like 10 lbs of beef and I gain fat
nobody [__] say you get full pretty
quick you know what I'm saying you don't
even want anymore you're like [__] this
beef dumb [__] same flavor and then you
get Le I'll star you know after just
hearing all this it is it's just so
common sense that I'm like wait why is
it that like we do all know this and it
sounds way more psychological than it
does like information it's like everyone
has the same information of you're right
like fish and carrots and celery is
probably going to be better than a
freaking double double that right I want
to hear a GU that lets me eat the
[__] double double in and it's in the
moment you know how many times like I
bring a meal prep right I'm like all
right I'm going to eat for lunch and
then I go holy [__] you see those Oreos
and then you just throw this away and I
start going ham on all that [__] you
know your bodybuilding coach is sitting
right here right I this is before
Jared's talking oh thank God he's
talking about me so like it's just in
the moment in the moment you have like
uh Temptations it's so [__] hard like
for some reason all the information gets
squeezed out out of your ears and you
forget that you know that the [__] so
it's not a lack of facts and education
it's more like discipline and just
psychological then huh well
psychological to the point I think
mostly people try to go all in at one
time so somebody's like I'm turning a
new Leaf it's time to be healthy they'll
try to go to the gym four to 6 days a
week immediately instead of just
starting off at like two they'll try to
eat like six healthy meals a day instead
of just like let me cut my pizza in half
today burnout let me just throw some
[__] in so just like 6040 healthy at
first do that for a while once you're
finally consistent and you're going to
the gym a couple times then maybe go
like 80 20 healthy to eating [__]
and like that's totally fine anytime I
get stop in a grocery store I'm like
look just eat half of what you if you
have a whole [__] Pizza in front of
you and normally you eat the whole thing
eat half of it tomorrow instead of the
whole thing and then make three
decisions like that per week and you're
going to have less calories I promise
it's literally that [__] simple yeah
I also find ways to cheat
too like I this is getting
darker look cuz I'll go like I'll go
like um I really like ice cream and I'm
like I'll start with just two spoonfuls
you know I'm like cool this week I I
stuck to a new routine a new habit next
week it's down to one spoonful but I'll
really make that one spoonful count and
that one spoon is probably it's like
four spoon I go
one can't even fit as long as you can
fool yourself you're winning that's the
good thing is the scale never lies so
when you [__] up you're like I only had
one spoon and you get on the scale
you're like son of a [__]
[__] what are the most common fool
yourself ways that are like that doesn't
really
work [__] you guys have client stories
where you let they well a lot of your
clients are like pros to like I'll fool
myself and I'll be like you know what
I'm going to have as much Coke Zero as I
want I thought you was just going to say
Coke for a second I was like holy [__]
cocaine as I want fresh your appetite
for sure I'm going to have fun tomorrow
I might be done I like the rhyme today's
video is brought to you by Uncommon
Goods are you tired of buying the same
gifts yep are you tired of receiving the
same gifts yep how are you going to get
into the ladies punani if you keep
giving them candy canes that's right I
guarantee you this if you have yellow
fever and you want yourself a beautiful
Asian princess she is not going to say
no I don't want to go on a with you if
you give her the Mochi donut kit oh it
is so special M imagine making Mochi
donuts and then your fingers touch M and
then you look each other in the eye and
you fall in love right away that's right
and that goes for you out there is all
you ladies that want a Asian K-pop boy
yourself go ahead and make Mochi donuts
with them this is the perfect gift
that's bringing and bridging cultures
together and you can get it at Uncommon
Goods so you could go out there and love
one another cuz that's what they're all
about supporting small businesses
independent businesses and artists so
you're going to find a whole variety of
cool and unique gift ideas for the
holiday season to get 15% off your next
gift go to uncommongoods.com sloff thee
that's uncommongoods.com sloff theere
for
15% off don't miss out on this limited
time offer Uncommon Goods we're all out
of the old now you know oh you know what
I did in the beginning of bodybuilding
prep which a little more of eway um I
did yourself out now well no I did this
where I was like I'll let I'll let uh uh
I I let it be dictated by divine
intervention okay so I was like what is
I so
me I was like what is I was like what
him I was the coach Sting the
plan
and I was like what does God want me to
do so I have a little Oreo uh uh jar at
home and I open it and I'll stick my
claw in oh my God and I go like this and
sometimes there's two sometimes there's
four so I let God dictate you can't how
many Oreos you're gra I just got I
thought you were going to say I got a
Jenga [__] with Oreos and if your boy
messes it up if it falls I eat the whole
thing really try to win speaking at Bart
level how much does God want me to have
and I'm like oh the whole thinge this
time thanks
God God is generous and wise I'm always
looking out God was giving you extra
calories and was not informing me for
some reason [__] know you need to
work on your communication I guess so
this is a CHR kind of stuff dude Jar's
like hey you need to cut your calories
again B's like but but
God was that religious man oh boy yeah
so so the fool yourself things most
common P yourself I mean one is like
Coke Zero is fine man by the way [__]
yes you can have as much of it as you
want it's not it's literally not
calories man sick you're good to go if
you're deleting the Zero part of the
phrase out in your head right now you're
going to die of a cocaine
open do your appetite oh yeah it makes
it makes everything so much better does
God does finally feel like the true self
you were supposed to be what you feel
Invincible 15 minutes at a time speaking
from current experience most of kind uh
bodybuilders or like athletes or um most
of the coaches at RP in general don't
they coach gen pop general population
just people trying to get in shape um
look good naked basically I see that's
Al a lot of my clients too I kind of at
this point get to like screen for
clients like are you actually serious
about this or not so when you screen for
them are you just like swiping right or
left on the figure yeah that's literally
what it
is I'm I I'm I'm going to be working
with Jared soon cuz he's a Jerry I had
to look at look at that hair you know
what I mean look at that dark skin I got
the you got the you're in the I climb
trees and grab coconuts bro let's go I'm
the type he's going to start drama
though you're going to fly to Missouri
yeah kind of fiery though watch out as
long as you have female relatives for
Jared to convert on one of the uh most
common self- sabotage is when people are
they're starting to weigh and measure
Their Food they'll go like let's say the
peanut butter and they put it on the
toast and then after they go oh or ice
cream or yogurt yeah yeah that doesn't
well they don't even know they're doing
it cuz they're just so used to like you
know as a kid you're like you don't want
to waste any so you lick it but then
everything you have to measure
accurately and I would say that's
probably one of the first things you got
to pay attention to if you start
measuring your food yeah it's like when
you get to that point too though you
know like like you said half your
audience here isn't even trying to be
excessively serious like bodybuilding
type of [__] so we even have Diet
templates at RP that are like simple uh
eating diet templates what they called
healthy simple simple temp it's l like
handful simple diet literally that's the
way you measure is like is there God's
corner like you could
like you guys going to add that yeah
think about it engineer got into a
scenario technically there's like a
little Callum it's like you can have 500
calories from whatever you want wow God
put that there so if you hear anything
else next time don't do it dare go over
that 500 [__] roaches and [__]
lightning I haven't read the Bible a
while but that [__] like
that wasn't that Locus yeah wouldn't it
be worse if it was Ro would
be spiders [__] don't say that you guys
know Jared's like irrationally afraid of
spiders really beyond anything reason we
should bring some no let's not too we
should bring some normal reaction to a
spider what what's a normal reaction to
a spider yeah what's normal and what's
your reaction he doesn't know what
normal is you'd have to ask somebody
normal yeah so you're taking a shower a
daddy long leg pops up what do you
do is pretty [__] freaky it
is sa spider was staying with a friend
of ours I would get out and I and he saw
a spider in her upstairs room where he
was sleeping he moved downstairs
permanently for the duration of the
multi-month stay cuz there were spiders
upstairs so you have to upstairs anymore
so like your Jerry's are afraid of
spiders you're not the one that they
call hell ABS you don't think the
spiders daddy long is looking at you
thinking to himself like I'm not going
to win this battle I I don't think that
they have thoughts like that all I think
that they just want to kill you to be
fair I think Jerry's are pretty good at
killing spiders I agree they'll be cool
with they live with them they probably
eat
them yeah but honestly that's a really
good like moral Parable for Jared cuz
you know like the [__] the little
train car experiment where that's like
six children on one in [__] yeah
Jared's like whatever [__] kill them
all but you're like all right there's a
big ass spider guarding Door full of
full of Jerry's and every single Jerry
in that little jail cell she she looks
like
this so sad and in their various tongues
we got some [__] speaking Cantonese
some Cambodian [__] Vietnamese and
they all in their own Jerry languages
they're like whatever like I all
traditional dresses have like rips in
them oh and and J Jerry says he's
powered by the [__] Force so he's
like God damn it and then [__] big
ass spider Jared what do you do man how
big is the spider yeah big like sizeable
tarantula yeah something bigger than you
can shake a stick at yeah I'd have to
I'd have to kill the spider yeah even if
it's nonpoisonous absolutely that's a re
are you kidding me really pure fear it's
like pure fear has to die I can't
Cate I can't move I can't move the
spider celebrate with them while the
spider's behind me and not freak out all
you do you take a cup you put it on
what's what's worse a jumping spider or
like a daddy long leg terrible
regardless yeah yeah but they're small
what are the spiders you sent me they
like shot their [__] webs in the air
flew yeah yeah they like they sort of
Glide down on trees and [__] yeah yeah
it's some [__] that happens in the
Amazon where you're like thank God
they're plowing the [__] rainforest
yeah get rid of it Captain Planet you
lost your home
sucks oh you're welcome by the way this
will be a sweet parking lot thank
God a great highrise oh I missed the
crazy flying spider quote no one
ever like save the rainforest why nuke
the Amazon that's our [__] get rid of
Captain plan I'm canceling
Australia and those poison
frogs they have those poison arrow frogs
too I [__] with a frog before a spider
for really boy a dummy snakes frogs
legit are poisonous spiders are mostly
like snakes are a trip I uh I was high
in mushrooms recently and uh I Came Upon
it snake right now uh I Came Upon a
snake and it was like a it was
interesting wait like for real or like
you just saw you just made it no he was
really there was it a garden hose then
you thought it was a
snake [__] man it was all my childhood
demons man they wrap me up uh that also
happened uh yeah it was like it was a
little disturbing in in a different kind
of way I was like oh some something like
ancestral that fear of snakes was it a
snake store or was it in the
wild
he was at the Reptile
Emporium mushrooms I'm like y this the
worst place I ever been to it was in it
was in uh like a nature area oh dang did
you stare at it for a while St fast bro
as long as you stared at that homeless
guy in New York you stared at that guy
for a long time yeah yeah were you guys
on streams other while you looking at
homeless people he was and I was looking
at homeless people was not the
activity
some [__] sociopath
[__] well they probably were on
sh themselves so they're just like we're
on the same wavelan we were just staring
into each other's eyes he and that that
man and I yeah he was asleep but that's
fine yeah yeah we were in New York City
Manhattan all right so we were in New
Jersey and we were like let's take
mushrooms together a few friends and
let's D Uber into Manhattan high as [__]
on mushroom sounds fun as soon as we get
out the [__] car um two ass Jerry's
walk by you remember that and you were
like in Miracle Paradise land right
exactly who they were and Jared's like
this is amazing there's tons of people
tons of different languages we were in K
toown half the [__] time and it was
it was just magic it wasn't on purpose
it just happened more like Jay telling
him all
[Laughter]
right I have to answer your actual
question that you asked much ear F the
question yeah sure go uh snacking
snacking can get some [__]
because you tell them eat this this that
they like I did it I'm not losing weight
you're like okay okay you like
thermodynamics and [__] you're wait wait
wait what else did you eat well I didn't
eat any of the meals I understand was
there anything else that entered your
mouth that was not either a toothbrush
or a a sex thing and they were like no
no carry the one yes I eat five handfuls
of gold fish every minute that I'm awake
every hey that's like that fat show and
they were giving them that and then they
had the cameras and then the people were
like yeah I'm not eating that much and
then they recorded and they're like yeah
you went to the fridge like 10 times
that's a biggest loser I forgot the name
of the show yeah but or people that work
in Munch yeah and so they were like not
even conscious of their eating that
that's a that's total [__] yeah
they're just lying to themselves I don't
even know I just put it on my mouth how
do you not know that you just ate you
know you're looking for goldfish dude
goldfish are delicious they're so good
what [__] what do they make goldfish
out of the people demand to know godamn
it these Mega corporations feeding our
children delicious goldfish God bless
them I bet it's like actually cheit but
it's in the shape of a goldfish I was
going to say it's definitely it's like a
cheit for sure it's just baked cheese it
crackers oh do the extra crispy
cheese-its come on dude toasty ones come
on the toasty ones you got get the one
with the Tabasco I don't know if they
still collaborate never do that I would
never do that that was good yeah okay
I'll try it
anything else besides snacking people
should watch out for snacking leads to
like a huge sunk cost people yeah well I
already [__] cheated so why you know
I'm just momentum in the other way well
it's like you know like I already
cheated on my girlfriend might as well
shoot this homeless guy
while there's levels to the [__] as soon
as you stop being a bad person it's just
better like it's all tomorrow I'll be a
good people think like that or their
diet they're like I had one goldfish and
I'm like suction a cheeseburger through
my ass one Reese's Peanut Butter Cup and
I'm like [__] it let's get two 4X and
cheated today so ice cream buy more then
Su my ass whatever it takes you shooting
a homeless guy is
pretty
[Music]